my name is alex bro
hey do you have any words of wisdom for
us uh no i just want to
ask a matter of question man uh about
the real estate if it doesn't mind
answering uh
the question is like uh what does he
think the next bubble is gonna burst
is the market gonna fall or is the kid
gonna keep on going up with the
mortgages right now because everybody
everything is selling like crazy
everybody's buying like crazy the rates
are down how long does he think this is
gonna last or what does he predict for
the future
is it going to be crashing like in 2008
or is it going to be going down slowly
or
what is what's his take on it oh i think
it's going to crash i think it's going
to be
2008 all over again i figure there's
probably they could probably keep it
propped up for another
what 12 months to 18 months maybe
but i mean how how long can you just
keep pumping money into a system until
it eventually
you know crashes so do you think it's
going to be like 2008 or is it's gonna
be worse especially with this two
trillion dollars bill that they passed
uh with the inflation coming up do you
think it's gonna be worse than 2008
or it's going to be something like 2008.
i honestly it's just a gut feeling like
i don't have the numbers i i wouldn't
even know how to begin to
calculate those numbers but i'd say i'd
say within the realm
of the finance the 2008 financial crisis
i'd say it's about probably
in the same that same realm i mean the
bottom line is the government will bail
it out and then it'll take
the problem is is this this time it's
not like
they have anybody to blame you know what
i'm saying like this time it's like who
do you blame for this
you can't blame wall street but they're
basically gonna blame this pandemic
right basically because of the pandemic
everything is going to be everybody's
going to get paid built up
but the difference is that you have to
think about the the the tarp
package but the tarp package was passed
they went and they they said we're going
to give the banks the money we're going
to take stock in exchange well keep in
mind about 90 to 95
of the tarp funds have been paid back
who's going to pay back the money
if the entire economy crashes they can't
go to the banks
it's not the bank's fault so it's just
going to have to be inflation
and inflation technically is just you're
just redistributing that
that loss among people so that means
that basically a loaf of bread doesn't
cost
five dollars it's costing 15 and 20
bucks so people are hungry
people aren't buying real estate there's
a crash people are being laid off they
don't work government has to come in so
i mean it could be the 2008 it could be
worse
i don't know i'm not i'm not that guy
i'm not an actuary i can't
cal you know crunch the numbers i'm not
that smart
but i think ultimately it does happen
you know i think what
to me i even did a video on my channel
about this like to me what i would do
ever because guys ask me all the time
what would you do with real estate if
you want to invest in real estate what
would you do what would you do
okay well what i do is because you don't
know if it's going to happen in the next
six months or it's going to happen the
next year what i would do is
i'd buy as many single families as i
could and i turn them into rooming
houses
i take the living room dining room and i
turn it into a bedrooms
so i take a three bedroom two bath or a
three bedroom one bath and turn it into
a five bedroom because the one thing
that's gonna happen is
people are gonna need to or cheap
housing you can put
bunk beds in them listen when people get
hungry things that they're saying right
now oh i'd never live in a rooming house
really
well when you're living on the street
you won't mind
bunking up with another guy in a room
as opposed to having to sleep on the
curb so
the fact is is that that's something you
can buy right now and it doesn't matter
if you're buying at the top of the
market because you're only buying them
for cash flow
so it doesn't make a difference doesn't
matter if you're up a hundred thousand
dollars upside down
if your cash flows a couple thousand
dollars a month what do i care if i'm
upside down
i could be upside down 12 million
dollars if my cash flow at the end of
the month
if my my positive is 20 grand
a month what do i care if i'm in debt or
upside down 12 million as long as i can
maintain it
and walk away with 10 or 20 grand a
month that's what i do
so i would be buying everything every
single every [ __ ] whole single family i
could buy right now
i'd buy it turn the living room dining
room into a bedroom and i'd rent them
out as rooming houses
obviously there's certain areas you
can't do it you can't do it in a pud you
can't do it in
a deed restricted community and you have
to look into it a little bit it's but
it doesn't matter you can buy houses
that nobody wants to live in right now
because guess what people that need to
live someone
somewhere will rent a room people are
renting rooms right now for 150 bucks
a month so i mean i'm sorry 150
a week they're renting rooms right now
for 150 a week easily
you can put you can put an ad on
craigslist right now for a room for rent
at 150 and within an hour you'll get 15
to 20 calls
guys desperate to rent the room because
the truth is look
if you're a 40 year old man and you're
divorced with two kids
you have to pay your child support you
have to there all these things you
cannot cut what
i can't cut food i have to eat i can't
cut
making my car payment or making my
insurance or my health insurance or
paying my
my child support what can i cut my
living expenses
that's the only thing i can cut so guess
what i want to see my kids i want to pay
my child support
i want to i want to be able to have
health care i want to be able to
have my car so i can go see my kids i
want to do all these things that i can't
cut so
i'm willing to shack up in a room i'm
willing to shack up in a buck if you
said hey i got a bunk bed you can rent
in a room with three other guys it's
gonna cost you a hundred dollars a week
you'd be shocked how many guys will say
i'll take it and be thankful
they'll be thankful to pay a hundred
dollars a week because they don't have a
choice
what's that going to be like in a year
and a half from now
people will be desperate to get into
those rooms so that's your own that's
the only thing that's a for sure thing
right now
but there's no way you cannot
continually pump money
into an economy and expect
that you're not going to have inflation
and a crash
and there's all these economists out
there that will say that'll say they'll
all say it's coming and then there are
other economists they're saying
oh no it'll be fine it'll be fine well
what the hell do you guys know anyway
everybody said everything was you know
peaches and cream in 2007.
in 2008 it was like oh my god this is
horrible why didn't we see this coming
people never want to see what's what's
right in front of them they don't want
to see what's bad
they always look on the bright side
and hey matt one more question what do
you think what about deflation
do you think we're experiencing right
now a deflation and the reason they're
pumping money into it is to to
prevent the deflation there's too much
stuff out there so they need
the purchasing power deflation or
inflation
no no deflation i i don't i don't know
anything about
i don't see any deflation that's
happening right this minute
what do you what do you mean what are
you basing that on i don't know what is
deflation
no it's when things are basically
basically
no basically deflation is when you don't
have the purchasing power you have too
much stuff
stored in warehouses and people don't
have money to buy it
so that way people go out of business
because they don't sell their products
so now that's basically the deflation
right you know okay you have the product
but nobody has the money to buy it
but then everybody's going out of
business no matter how cheap they try to
sell it nobody's gonna have the power to
buy it because there's no money into the
economy
you know it's something i feel like
that's what's happening right now
i don't know that's what i'm asking you
do you think maybe that's the scenario
of like
the reason they're pumping so much money
into it or whatever or i don't know
i have no idea i mean i think they're
pumping money into the economy just
because they're trying to keep everybody
going right now and everybody's
bills being paid and people you know
eating i mean i i think that's what
they're
where my question is does all these
trillions come from i mean
obviously it's just you know the money
is not obviously they
i heard you know what i heard the other
day i heard more money has been
printed in the last four years
than in the entire history of the united
states
i don't know i don't know
but isn't that the causes the houses are
going up because the money are
devaluating so you got to pay more money
for the same thing
you think the house is going up in value
but what's happening is the value of the
dollar is going down so you gotta put up
with more dollars
to buy the same thing you think oh my
god my house is half a million i bought
it with three hundred thousand
but the but the inflation is so bad that
you actually have to put up more money
to buy the same thing
isn't that the same concept over here
well i think i think that
there's a lack of inventory on the
market right now as far as houses are
concerned
because the banks are obviously they're
still lending money
and people are putting money into houses
right now because they don't know what
the future holds but here's the
the nice thing about buying a house if
you buy a house for 200 000
even if you're paying at top market okay
even if you're paying 40 000
then more than the house was worth a
year ago the fact is
is you're buying a house with a fixed
mortgage payment so your payment's
fifteen hundred dollars a month so
whether that
whether if there's inflation and
let's say let's say even if it doesn't
matter if there's a crash and it doesn't
matter or and it
doesn't matter if the prices keep going
up you've got a fixed rate
so you have you have a fixed payment
from here on out
so people dump money into homes right
now because they just don't know
what their dollar what the dollar is
going to be worth in the future
but at least they'll have a home over
their head with a fixed payment
so if the prices go up they're good if
they go down they're still good
because if you were to take a hundred
thousand dollars a hundred thousand
dollars might not be worth a hundred
thousand dollars
in two years from now or a year from now
but your house will
your house payment will remain the same
i don't know if that makes sense i
probably didn't explain that very well
[Laughter]
but